for years are really even for decades
the gun people as they're sometimes
known the pro-gun activists the gun
fetishists the National Rifle
Association other groups they've been
warning us they've been telling us we
absolutely need more guns we need more
guns in more places we need guns
everywhere because the government could
become tyrannical it's possible that
someone might try to turn the United
States into a police state it could be a
president who is a totalitarian
nightmare who might do something like
deploying the military across the
country and those exact same people have
been silent as Donald Trump has said he
doesn't care what governor's say he'll
send in the military if he wants to to
suppress protests that are protected by
the First Amendment and in fact as we
saw the National Guard and very
militarized police units and riot squads
deployed to protests around the country
which have been overwhelmingly peaceful
the NRA and the gun people have said
nothing we saw a riot squad take down
Martin Gugino an unarmed 75 year old man
knocked over by police hitting his head
bleeding from his ear spending nearly a
week in the hospital and the president
got involved to attack the protester
rather than the police who did this this
is exactly what the NRA and others have
been warning us about and as matt Cohen
writes for Mother Jones all of those
people all of those groups have been
absolutely silent Wayne LaPierre from
the NRA wrote 25 years ago that it's
possible that quote jackbooted
government thugs would get more power to
take away our constitutional rights
destroy our property even injure us if
you can imagine that if assault weapons
were banned which was the discussion in
1995 when Wayne LaPierre wrote that we
saw during the Barack Obama presidency
the NRA other gun groups activists fear
mongering that Barack Obama the scary
half black possibly Muslim foreign guy
was going to come in
everybody's guns he was gonna confiscate
all the guns and it was a true liberal
bogeyman and in reality Barack Obama
presided over one of the largest
expansions in gun ownership a boon for
gun sales that we have seen in American
history because of that fear-mongering
and now the NRA is silent the NRA is
silent that maybe George Floyd should
have had a weapon to defend himself as
they sometimes like to say about people
in various sticky situations as maybe
the term is the NRA completely silent
about the repression of protests and
police brutality and support and
encouragement of that brutality from the
president and for many of his Republican
colleagues and yet when state
governments were saying wear a mask two
months ago that was supposedly
tyrannical repression by the government
which had the gun people out in force at
state capitals and on city streets the
reality of course is that the NRA
and these other groups believe the
Second Amendment is fundamentally a
defense against liberals that's really
what you need guns for to defend
yourself against liberals and fake
liberal bogeyman the NRA doesn't really
care about gun rights or tyranny they
care about selling guns and funneling
money to Republicans and it would be
very problematic for the NRA to say at
this point listen don't we need people
to take up guns to protect ourselves
from the militarized tyrannical police
and riot gear it would be terrible for
optics if they said that it would put
them at odds with the establishment it
would be seen as encouraging violence
and when they talk about defending the
gun rights of law-abiding citizens the
idea in their heads is of a white
conservative man now of course look I
listen I've been around enough to know
they include carefully selected safe
instances of defending the gun rights of
soccer moms with a handgun in their
purse and you know picking out some
black folks who hold up as look here
here's some examples but the silence
that we're seeing
in light of the recent protests and
repression by police surprises nobody
who's been paying attention
remember falando castile falando castile
was a black man who legally owned a gun
did exactly as instructed by police was
calm complied and he was killed without
real consequences for the officers
involved where was the NRA and after the
fact the NRA came up with this sort of
post hoc rationalization from their
spokeswoman Dana Loesch I don't know if
Dana Loesch is still a spokeswoman she
was at the time and she said well the
reason we're not coming to the defense
of falando cast the illegal gun owner
who did exactly what police asked and
was still killed happened to be black is
he not only had a firearm he was in
possession of a controlled substance at
the same time he had drugs on him and
that's illegal and that's how the NRA
was able to say who we don't have to go
out there and defend volando castile
because he had drugs on him ah right
that must have been what it was and
before i forget the nra also exists i
alluded to this before to funnel dark
money to republicans through political
advertising we saw that in 2016 with the
Trump campaign they the NRA helped Trump
get elected by funneling shadowy money
directly into pro Trump campaign online
advertising campaigns investigations
into that were started they were
attempted they didn't go very far I
think you won't be shocked to hear so
again back when it was protests because
the government wants us to stay home and
wear masks when we're out
they brought their guns out and I was
thinking that this is the government
tyranny Public Health guidelines like
mask wearing and holding off on haircuts
for the time being this is the
government tyranny and then now as we
see heavily militarized police forces
come out in response to protests about
government right I mean when we talk
about police using force and killing
people that is government overusing
force the government might become too
radical people are missing they're gone
and in fact they're criticizing the
protesters so never ever ever ever again
if you ever fell for it to begin with
should you fall for any of these talking
points we need guns because the
government might become tyrannical we
support we we always come out in support
of people who have been victimized by
actors elements of government and lawn
for it's it's that's not what it's ever
been about it's about selling guns it's
about defending primarily their main
constituents which are conservative
white men with exceptions of course and
as a funnel conduit for getting money to
Republican politicians that's what they
exist for and they're proving it every
single day